torino unprecedented sanctions
pressure the situation in the Russian
fuel and energy sector remains
quite stable moreover, a number of
key indicators even show
growth, in particular, the level of oil production with
gas condensate in June of this year
reached 10.7 million barrels per day, which
is half a million barrels above sea
level
gas production for the period from January to May
decreased, but significantly by only
two percent, such
stability of work was achieved
largely due to timely measures
to support and develop the industry
strengthening technological independence
increasing the depth of oil and
gas processing as you know, Russian
energy companies are reliable
responsible partners  At the same time,
due to Western calls to abandon
Russian energy resources, world markets
are still in a fever, so in anticipation of a
shortage, the price of Brent oil
reached $130 per barrel in mid-June.
In recent days, prices have fallen
by $20.  -30 dollars this happened against the backdrop of
forecasts of a slowdown in the global
economy and the onset of economic
difficulties in it
once again shows that sanctions
restrictions on Russia
cause much more damage to precisely those countries
that introduce them, further
use of the sanctions policy can
lead to even more severe, without
exaggeration, even  catastrophic
consequences in the global energy sector,
as is well known, and the European Union was conducting another
sanctions package against Russia with an
oil barbie, for this decision,
domestic companies should already be
ready for the so-called blitzkrieg that
our ill-wishers conceived in
relation to Russia, which is economically close, he of
course failed, but
that's what he wanted  pay attention, but
still, it damages us for the night, I see that
some colleagues are already,
as it were, somewhat
superficially beginning to relate to the
measures that we must take to
stop possible threats; they
don’t give a damn about these
sanctions.  away everything is already in the past we
coped with everything and
feel confident yes you should feel
confident but the risks we must see the
risks I keep